make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are covering Karen Gillan's
uncanny x-men or at least part of it
specifically we're covering the story of
the Dreaming celestial now there's a few
things to understand here technically we
are kind of picking up in the middle of
a run which is something that I don't
usually advocate doing but I kinda want
to test the waters to see how you guys
respond and the Dreaming celestial I
think has always been an interesting
character that I've always wanted to
cover but with regards to this story
there's a few things going on the first
thing is that this is part of what's
called Regenesis and Regenesis was the
aftermath to schism now schism is a
story that we've covered and you'll find
a link to that down in the description
but that was basically werewolves Rayne
and Cyclops ended up splitting off the
off the x-men teams and created their
own individual xfinty so Wolverine you
had a story called Wolverine and the
x-men which basically covered Wolverines
time as the head the headmaster of the
Jean Grey school of higher learning and
then you had Cyclops who remained in
Utopia off the coast of San Francisco
and had the Xavier school for gifted
youngsters Wolverine school was back in
in Westchester right but basically the
entire community was split now the
reason why that matters is because
schism goes into Regenesis Regenesis
goes into ex sanction and ex sanction is
the prelude for Avengers vs. x-men right
it's basically cable showing up and
saying okay guys so you're just gonna
happen Pope Sommers is gonna have some
crazy things going on and the Avengers
are gonna want to take her you got to
keep her safe that kind of a thing
that's kind of what led to the x-men
basically being so standoffish against
the Avengers in the first place was
because of the message of cable during
extinction but the other thing about
this is that this basically kind of
comes in the aftermath of the death of
mr. sinister and ethically speaking mr.
sinister he died during the events of
the aftermath of rogue in the hecka tomb
the idea here was that as most of the
guys know whenever rogue touches someone
she absorbs their powers and their
memories there was a point where the
x-men were in space and rogue basically
came into contact with what was called
the Hecate tomb which was just like this
giant bomb essentially of the Shiar but
what it meant is she came into contact
with like all these different
consciousness more or less and the
result was that all these billions of
essences essentially kind of sit her
into a catatonic state it lasted that
way until you gotten to Messiah Complex
and then when Hope Summers was born and
Hope Summers was taken by mystique in
gambit basically hope was touched to
rogue and then rogue woke up but during
that process sinister was killed and so
sinister had remained dead for quite
some time now there
a couple instances where he tried to
come back he came back as like Miss
sinister like a female for example none
of it really seemed to work out exactly
how it was supposed to this is the first
full return of sinister following his
death and he's will just kind of born
out of just something out there if it's
kind of crazy like he literally just
kind of falls out of this tank now we'll
find out what it is and how all that
works but that was kind of the prelude
to what was going on in the events
leading up to this but essentially
Sinister's is fully and totally alive
the other big thing and this is kind of
a last the last big thing that gets here
is as we get into this story of course
you have the Dreaming celestial standing
you know thousands of feet tall in the
middle of San Francisco and the reason
why this happens goes back to uncanny
x-men issue number 512 by Matt Fraction
the way this played out is you basically
had the x-men kind of jumping back in
time to see if they could understand
like the origin of the mutant gene and
that kind of a thing but essentially
that information was basically buried
underground and the Dreaming celestial
popped up on top of it and so at that
moment that's why it's here now what
also has to deal with has to do with the
idea of like the High Evolutionary
meddling with it different things like
that but the jury Celestials only
appeared a handful of times probably the
most notable instance is when it
achieved essentially a role beyond its
initial purpose and it basically joined
the fulcrum into traveling beyond you
know whoever it was supposed to go but
basically you know it's only appeared a
handful of times but it's an exceedingly
powerful celestial and if you guys want
we can do like a full explanation on the
Dreaming celestial right like the
Dreaming celestial explained but
basically sinister shows up here in an
amélie incapacitate one person because
the Dreaming Celestials kind of become a
bit of a tourist attraction and then the
other person kind of begs for their life
but soon as she doesn't really care he
ends up basically you know killing both
of these guys and that's basically it
and then he ends up touching the
Dreaming celestial and when that happens
things begin to pop off now what we end
up doing here is switching over to the
x-men are switching over to Cyclops and
Emma Frost with what Cyclops refers to
as the extinction team now the
extinction x-men team is a powerhouse of
a team off the top of my head I can
count to Omega level mutants possibly no
300 mega level mutants possibly four
you've got Emma Frost who's definitely
Omega level you've got storm who's on
mega level you've got magneto who's
Omega level and then you got magic right
so like white off the bat you got a team
with four omega-level mutant like
they're exceedingly powerful some are
official some are not but let's be
honest with ourselves
magneto is up there and so is magic but
for those of you guys who were also kind
of curious to what you've got
that robotic looking person is called
danger now danger goes back to uh to
astonishing x-men by Joss Whedon and
John Cassaday and it was basically this
idea that like the Danger Room became
sentient it was a weird bit of a story
but it essentially became a kind of
physical being right and that's more or
less where it comes from that's why you
see this being being referred to as
danger now this also comes out of fear
itself that's when you ended up having a
colossus becoming the new juggernaut
right and so that's why you sort of see
this this interesting situation where
dangers talking to Colossus and it's
like hey you should calm down in case
your other self should make an
appearance on the response of magic is
now he's all under control everything's
copacetic this kind of came in the
aftermath of that when Colossus was
juggernaut for quite some time the idea
here is that the extinction team of
Cyclops is kind of a reflection of the
change in his character we've talked
about that before in Marvel where you
basically had Cyclops who was originally
like the boy scout of the x-men right he
believed in Xavier stream you couldn't
talk him out of it right he was a
believer as time began to progress and
specifically coming out of house of M
and in really going into like deadly
Genesis when he when Cyclops basically
learned that he had a third brother that
Xavier never told him about and his
brother 3rd brother had basically died
you know Xavier sent him on a suicide
mission of sorts
Cyclops his view of Xavier began to
shift the fact that he and him Frost
were the ones basically running the
x-men after the events of house of M and
even for a time the events leading up to
it because Xavier was nowhere to be
found basically meant that when Xavier
returned Cyclops was like no we're
running the show you can just sit there
and just kind of be an adviser and
that's basically it which Xavier did but
what it meant is that it's time began to
progress in Marvel Comics Cyclops became
more and more militaristic right it
became more and more a militarized it
even became more of a villain falling
more in line with like the way magneto
used to be and that's why this kind of
team exists here is because Cyclops has
become extremely heavy-handed in so far
as like humanity hates us humanity has
it out forced basically we need to have
a strike team available so we can hit
them as hard as possible if they hit us
that's why the extinction team is one so
exceedingly powerful but to like full of
such heavy hitters and you know that's
why I've had it that's why it has its
name
for the most part the x-men operating
out of utopia or just kind of monitoring
you know so like younger recruits to go
through their regular training where
they learn martial arts from Psylocke
different things like that but for the
most part you don't really see a whole
lot do it's just kind of a recap of what
the various teams are doing but in the
midst of all this some
we added a brand ends up yanking Cyclops
and Emma Frost away now so a little bit
a little bit about this because the peak
and sword will become a talking point in
the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe those two guys who saw
spider-man far from home and he saw the
post-credits scenes a sword of course is
a sentient world's observation and
response department Abigail brand is the
one who led it at that point in time in
Marvel Comics right now in the present
day in 2020 it's led by Carol Danvers as
far as I'm aware and it's called the
Alpha Flight Program instead of sword
but basically Abigail Branham sword were
created by Joss Whedon and John Cassaday
from back in astonishing x-men but their
idea was to essentially introduce a
space version of shield so where shield
monitors earth sword monitors space and
the idea is that there's a lot of
questions that are being asked here with
regards to sword you know especially
with the fact that like the dreaming
Celestials popped up here because the
dreaming celestial is a celestial
basically meaning that an alien entity
is on earth and so because of the fact
that sword doesn't really directly
involve itself in the goings-on on earth
that's really confined a more to shield
they end up contacting the x-men
basically saying you guys are kind of
the residential experts when it comes to
these sort of things but we're also
contacting the Avengers and you
basically end up getting the extinction
team that shows up here the problem is
that once they arrived The Dreaming
celestial begins to kind of kind of
change and modify its physical body
begins to break down and dissolve and in
in place of its head you basically end
up getting the head of sinister did what
sinister had done is he it essentially
infiltrated the Dreaming celestial and
taken it over and so sinister kind of
like becomes God now of course this
leads to the to the involvement of Namor
the Submariner stories like like moments
like this and especially during Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers is
why a lot of fans who weren't really
named were the Submariner fans before
have become such huge fans now right
they're just kind of like this guy is
legit you know it's because of
storytelling like this but essentially
what you end up getting here is is
basically the the body of the Dreaming
celestial becoming unstable as the head
of sinister basically leaves right and
so what this does and probably one of
the most impressive displays of power is
you end up having a few things happening
the first is that as the body explodes
right as is this energy begins to
explode outwards you end up having
Colossus who sent flying Emma Frost
turns into her diamond form but her arms
blown off right so we'll talk more about
that here in a second you end up having
magneto using the totality of his power
to basically reassemble the body of the
Dreaming celestial and then hold the
body in place is this kind of a
instrument
aníbal tasks and it's really beginning
to sort of take its toll on magneto but
it's a huge it's a huge Display of power
right because what magneto is doing
right now is holding together the body
of a God he's acting as its mind
basically holding it together and so
with that being the case one thing to
also understand is that with Emma Frost
diamond form that was introduced during
Grant Morrison's run in new x-men a
secondary mutation that happened during
es4 extinction the way this works is
it's very similar to like the absorbing
man crusher creel right so we have
pressure Creoles in like a stone form
and like his arm gets cut off he can put
his arm you know as long as he remains
in his stone form he can put his arm
back in place and then snap back into
his human form and it'll heal in place
it'll hurt like hell but it'll go back
to normal the way that it's supposed to
as far as I'm aware with Emma Frost it's
much the same way would that be in the
case you kind of have you know Colossus
turning into his into his Jever not form
and then essentially going after the
head of sinister but the problem is that
once sinister arrives at is you know
ultimate location he basically ends up
arriving at this Museum of sorts and
then seems to turn everybody in the
general vicinity into sinister right
that's that's kind of what goes on that
what follows this it's basically a great
big huge fight right you've got Hope
Summers is kind of off in the distance
and she's using a giant gun now there's
a couple reasons why this is happening
the first is because Hope Summers is a
prodigious shooter and sniper because of
her time spent with cable and so with
that being you know with that in mind
Hope Summers is also a little unstable
when it comes to her abilities right she
does kind of have the five lights we do
sort of know how if powers work but she
still also at that age where she's
emotionally vulnerable right so she
begins to sort of freak out or lash out
where things become too overwhelming for
her then nobody really knows exactly how
her powers would manifest and so what
this does is it leads to like this
massive conflict between these x-men and
all these different Sinister's now in
the middle of all this suddenly Cyclops
is contacted by Abigail brand and have a
you know who's kind of like okay look I
get what's going on I mean you know but
this is like a really bad time all
hell's basically breaking loose and
she's like no no you don't really
understand what's going on like there
are signatures heading towards earth the
Celestials are coming right like the the
awakening of the Dreaming celestial has
basically brought all the other
Celestials here like they're making
their way to earth
figure out what to do or they're going
to annihilate us all either Celeste show
up here and they don't like what they
see that's the end of earth and
everybody on it and so with that being
the case you know you immediately end up
having one of the Sinister's who shows
up and basically sends a kind of
to the x-men come and meet with sinister
prime he wants to talk to you guys big
kind of suspect is a trap but it's okay
what choice do we really have you know
we're facing potential annihilation we
just kinda need to have these
conversations right and so when they
show up there and they start talking to
sinister the first question is why like
what's what's the whole point of this
why are you doing any of this and the
responses sinister is kind of this
long-winded explanation of like because
I can but Sinister's always been
obsessed with evolution specifically the
ability to push himself beyond and
that's what he's been doing that these
various duplicates that he has that
sinister will essentially die but every
time he does die whatever version comes
back that's birthed out of that matrix
will come back better than the one that
died right so he'll always come back
more intelligent having maintained all
the knowledge he had and then learning
even more knowledge along the way right
so each version is an improved version
so sinister version one in version 2
version 3 version 4 so on and so forth
not only that what you end up having him
doing is basically using the power of
the Dreaming celestial to essentially
harness the minds of various people who
were out there now this is kind of a big
thing that we need to establish here is
that you have Emma Frost in her diamond
form she is completely and totally
immune to any form of telepathic attack
when she's in her diamond form there's
no way to to influence her in that way
that was established back during new
x-men and has been consistently
solidified over the history of Marvel
Comics since that time but what's really
big here is Colossus with the the helmet
of the juggernaut is totally immune to
the telepathic power of the Dreaming
celestial as well this is no small thing
because what this means is that these
two characters these two earthbound
characters one of whom is a mutant of
the highest order a telepath of the
highest order
the other one who's basically imbued by
the power of an other-dimensional demon
are immune to the power of a celestial
or at least to this aspect of a
Celestials power that's a very big thing
but in the middle of all that you know
what you end up gaining a sinister who
kind of gives him a frost a hard time
insofar as saying like when he's talking
to Cyclops they're like Cyclops has
first made of course meaning Jean Grey
what's the highest genetic quality vie
of ride that was available and when she
died he went with like the next best
thing basically saying Emma Frost is a
poor man's Jean Grey which he is and so
as a result of that how many guys can
tell me that I'm wrong come on like
anybody who's a dream gray fan will be
like yeah
emilie's okay but like let's be honest
with ourselves you know and so sinister
just to kind of prove a point ends up
stepping outside right well all the
x-men aside from like Emma Frost at this
point because Colossus you know helmets
been taken off while they're all
basically subdued by his power and Emma
Frost has to maintain her diamond form
lest she be taken over by the the
abilities of sinister as well sinister
to prove a point
steps outside and then is immediately
shot by Hope Summers and then when that
happens you know it's kind of like okay
telepathic control is down you know and
Cyclops is like everybody let's go you
know let's do our thing and then like
another sinister takes over and that's
kind of the point that he was proving
here each one of these Sinister's are
autonomous but they're all part of a
whole right there are all basically
clones and they can all think for
themselves they all share like a
singular consciousness right so like
they're they're all kind of like we do
our thing you know like we have our
particular roles that we play
that's what sinister says that like once
these clones are created that clone goes
out into the community and immediately
knows what its role is supposed to be
and then fulfills that role so it's
autonomous in that regard but like at
any point in time each one of these guys
are essentially sinister prime that if
the sinister prime dies a new one steps
up and takes his place and seemingly the
entire collective consciousness makes
that choice and so it's one of these
things were it's like I can never truly
die that's kind of the point and kind of
the goal of what sinister was looking to
achieve here this is one of the things
is essentially kind of carried on into
all-new all-different marvel and
especially going into Jonathan Hickman's
dawn of X now for my part I didn't catch
that right off the bat during that point
I assume they were all duplicates from
bar-sinister coming out of seeker worst
but one of the things that a lot of you
guys said was no no no no that's not
what's going on because Secret Wars
basically reset everything from before
Secret Wars that bar-sinister
technically doesn't exist anymore that
those are all basically duplicates of
sinister from this story right from the
story of the dream you celestial so
kudos to you guys catching something
that I missed that's always kind of the
hope really you know what how much
explain that like it gets to a point
where a lot of you guys are just kind of
like no wrong actually man let me let me
correct you here I kind of like that
right because it means that like I
learned from you guys and you guys
learned from me and I always kind of
enjoy that that sort of give-and-take
that goes back and forth and so what
this does is it basically leads to the
arrival of danger right kind of using
her abilities to essentially create a
kind of Danger Room that basically
overrides the mental faculties of
sinister for time because keep in mind
this is basically you know the Dreaming
celestial but if it's mind can be taken
over can basically be hacked but it is
in some ways a kind of
but when the xmin basically go to make
their escape there's still all these
Sinister's here and that's why things
were to begin to pop off because in that
moment Emma Frost is kind of like okay
so like we don't have a choice
Emma Frost basically reverts back into
her human form and then uses her
telepathy to dominate the minds of all
the Senators who were there because that
sinister is no longer in the mind of the
Dreaming celestial but using her power
and basically seizing control of the
Dreaming celestial to shut down the
minds of all the other Sinister's who
were there basically leads to the to the
Dreaming Celestials head basically going
awry and then of course sinister
re-emerges again and again that's the
nature of it is this always kind of like
I will always come back I'll always
return
I'm currently channeling the power of a
god but realizing that the Celestials
are coming here sinister kind of bails
out but that's one of the things that he
says it's like the Celestials will come
here and the Celestials will destroy
everything but I will always exist I
will continue to exist not because the
Celestials will destroy the world but
because the Celestials will cleanse all
life on the world now this is one thing
to sort of understand because one half
of it is the hubris of sinister but the
other half is also because when when the
Celestials showed up during the second
host and they eradicated the kingdom of
Atlantis and its capital city lumeria it
basically laid waste to the deviants and
almost completely and totally
annihilated them but what it essentially
did is that Saleh Celestials destroying
their capital city and then whatever
happened would happen right it wasn't
really their intention to annihilate all
life on that world
maybe that's what sinister is referring
to you but the reality is that when the
Celestials show up here and they
basically look at a particular race and
they see them moving beyond their
station or infringing on celestial
property or anything like that the
Celestials will cleanse all organic life
right that's the way this works right
that's kind of how those slushees have
always functioned but regardless it
seems to be a little bit of hubris on
the side of sinister you know he
basically ends up taking his pistol
putting it to himself and then you know
offing himself you know kind of this
idea that like the solute that he'll
always find a way to survive doesn't
necessarily seem to be the case but with
the other you know the other Celestials
arriving here you end up having like
Cyclops who basically goes up to him and
it's like okay so like let's have a
conversation
essentially all this stuff popped up
with sinister you know like all these
things went crazy with him we're not
here to to cause like you know any
problems or anything like that this
planet is under our protection
this Dreaming celestial is on our planet
we're here to protect him and you know
it may have looked like we were ceding
some kind of a conflict or something
like that but the x-men are basically
pleading for their life now the saving
of the ex
and comes through hope summers and hope
summer says you should leave and the
result is that this Celestials end up
leaving now there's a couple of things
that we can extrapolate from this right
the first is that the Celestials realize
what hope summers will become that hope
summers will become the Phoenix and so
as you know because that she will have
an insane amount of power the power
enough to essentially destroy the
Celestials if you chose to the other
part of this is a dreaming celestial
just points to the sky the Celestials
are like okay cool so they end up
leaving so hopeful immers had nothing to
do with it we can infer either one of
those things miss particular conflict
but you know this is kind of a moment
where the x-men basically witness all
these different people who were here
watching all these things unfold and and
initially where the exponent cut are
kind of like yeah you know we're
constantly hated different things like
that
they kind of see themselves is being
able to take a bit of a foothold in the
city of San Francisco because no one's
throwing things at them now with regards
to the x-men being here one of the
reasons why nobody's attacking them in
San Francisco goes back to the origin of
utopia in the sense that the x-men were
given that location by the mayor of San
Francisco he was the Governor of
California but I'm pretty sure it was
the mayor of San Francisco who gave them
that area you know off its coast and
said like this belongs to you now
and while humanity you know in San
Francisco wasn't necessarily in favor of
mutants they were certainly like a lot
more enlightened than were you found
like the friends of humanity and like
Alabama right like I mean that's more or
less where you found like down in the
south or like Williams strikers
purifiers up north people who were
essentially east of the Mississippi you
know everybody on the East Coast was
just like super prejudiced and everybody
on the west coast was was still pretty
prejudiced but of just a little less
what on the less you know it's it's an
interesting story and I definitely dig
it but let me know what you guys think
you know if you guys want to see more of
this kind of thing as far as I'm aware
this is the only one that really
involves the The Dreaming celestial um
you know as far as the x-men go there
may be a few other stories here and
there but we can kind of follow the
aftermath of schism if you guys want if
you guys want to see more of that stuff
but regardless if you are new here to
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
Robin Corps if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]